en este vídeo vamos a ver las reacciones
redox biológicas de alcoholes y fenoles
del lado izquierdo tenemos la molécula
de
qué es un alcohol de 2 carbonos el
carbono que más nos interesa es este
carbono de aquí que tiene un enlace a
este átomo de oxígeno en el hígado el
etanol es oxidado a de canal del lado
derecho está la molécula de
al un aldehído de 2 carbonos y
nuevamente nos interesa el carbono de
amarillo una manera sencilla de saber
que el etanol ha sido oxidado a etanol
es viendo que del lado izquierdo tenemos
un enlace de ese carbono al oxígeno y
del lado derecho
tenemos dos enlaces de ese carbono al
oxígeno por lo que un aumento en el
número de enlaces al oxígeno indican
oxidación
también podríamos asignar estados de
oxidación a este carbono y veríamos que
hay un aumento en el estado de oxidación
de ese carbono también podríamos pensar
en electrones entonces leo el león hace
querer pérdida de electrones es
oxidación ganancia de electrones es
reducción si pienso en estos electrones
de aquí en magenta puedo ver que estos
electrones se separan de la molécula de
etanol pérdida de electrones es
oxidación el etanol es oxidado si el
etanol es oxidado algo más debe ser
reducido así es como funcionan las
reacciones redox y lo que he reducido es
más aquí del lado izquierdo
este es un ave más que significa
nicotina me da adenina de nucleótido la
adenina
se esconde en esta parte r y tenemos un
anillo con base en nitrógeno con un
grupo funcional a medida del lado
derecho para la porción nicotina medida
de la molécula
más una carga formal en este metro g no
nos da n además entonces esta es
nicotina me da adenina pico nucleótido
enea de más y dado que el etanol es
oxidado n además debe ser reducido
reducción significa ganancia de
electrones por lo que en él además va a
ganar esos electrones en color magenta
del etanol si pensamos en un mecanismo
posible si tomo estos electrones entre
el oxígeno y el hidrógeno y los nuevos
hacia acá eso formaría un doble enlace
entre el carbono y el oxígeno pero
habría demasiados enlaces en este
carbono de aquí por lo que los
electrones en magenta se van a mover
de carbono de aquí abajo en línea de más
a este carbono esto empujaría a estos
electrones hacia acá
y eso empujaría a estos electrones hacia
el nitrógeno
entonces sin mostrarnos qué sucede con
el movimiento de todos esos electrones
en el lado derecho este carbono de
arriba ya tenía un hidrógeno unido a él
y gana otro hidrógeno con dos electrones
los dos electrones eran los de color
magenta entonces este hidrógeno de aquí
es este hidrógeno y los electrones en
magenta se mueven hacia el anillo y
luego también tendríamos electrones pib
que se mueven hacia acá además teníamos
un par de electrones disponibles que se
movieron al nitrógeno y seguimos
teniendo algunos electrones py en el
lado derecho
y entonces esta molécula se llama n
sí
h
ha ganado el equivalente a un y duro un
hidrógeno con dos electrones y entonces
podemos ver que n además gana dos
electrones y ganancia de electrones
reducción por lo que en además es
reducido a nh dado que n además es
reducido
permite que el etanol se ha oxidado por
lo que nos referíamos a n además como un
agente oxidante
es el agente oxidante del etanol aun
cuando él mismo está siendo reducido
esto es algo confuso para algunos
estudiantes de química general muy bien
de este lado tenemos la molécula de enea
de h y esta reacción es catalizada por
una enzima y la enzima es
col
de es
pero
una
ah
bien esto es catalizado por la enzima
alcohol deshidrogenasa muy bien y esta
es una reacción reversible
entonces si pensamos en la reacción
reversa pensaríamos en el led anal
siendo reducido a etanol
entonces si el led anal es reducido a
etanol en el a dh sería oxidado a n
además pensemos en un mecanismo en el
que oxide moss nh y reduzcamos el etanol
si tomo este par de electrones
disponibles en el nitrógeno y los
regreso hacia acá en su empujaría a
estos electrones hacia acá
y ahora los electrones en magenta en
este enlace de aquí atacarían a este
carbono de aquí
entonces los electrones en magenta
podemos pensar que los electrones en
magenta están aquí y podemos pensar en
esto como un hidruro un hidrógeno con
dos electrones dándole una carga formal
de menos solo y aunque hemos visto en
vídeos anteriores que el y duro no es
necesariamente el mejor núcleo fino
podemos pensar en esto como un ataque
núcleo físico si se les facilita porque
este carbono de aquí sería parcialmente
positivo por lo que los electrones con
carga negativa atacarían a ese carbono y
al hacerlo eso empujaría a estos
electrones
para que para que tomen este protón de
aquí
y eso nos daría nuestra molécula de
etanol y convertiría en hd vuelta a n
además y podemos pensar en nh siendo
oxidado ya que está perdiendo está
perdiendo dos electrones los electrones
en magenta y pérdida de electrones es
oxidación y dado que nh es un agente
para la reducción del etanol a etanol
podemos decir que nh es el agente
reductor en este ejemplo y la mejor
manera de recordar que nh es el agente
reductor es viendo que es el que tiene
el hidrógeno tiene el hidruro que es
capaz de ser el agente para la reducción
por lo que nh es el agente reductor
esta conversión de enea de más a nh y
viceversa es extremadamente importante
en bioquímica esto ocurre en varias
reacciones bioquímicas por lo que es
importante entender qué está ocurriendo
con esos electrones en estas moléculas
otro ejemplo bioquímico de redox tenemos
del lado izquierdo fenol esta es nuestra
molécula de fenol
nuevamente nos interesa este carbono que
está unido a este oxígeno hay muchas
maneras de oxidar fenoles si oxidamos
un fenol con algo como el reactivo de
iones con di cromato de sodio ácido
sulfúrico y agua sería capaz de oxidar
al fenol para obtener esta molécula de
la derecha que llamamos denso quignón a
esta de aquí es una molécula de adn
no
rápidamente podemos ver que este carbono
tiene dos enlaces carbono oxígeno por lo
que ha sido oxidado por lo que el fenol
puede ser oxidado a venzo kino na usando
varios reactivos orgánicos una vez que
tienes venzo quignón a la puedes reducir
a esta molécula de la derecha llamada
pero
no no
de nuevo hay varios reactivos orgánicos
que pueden reducir venzo quignón aa
hidroquinona y luego de hidroquinona se
puede oxidar la hidroquinona para tener
venzo quignón a de nuevo fácilmente
nuevamente en química orgánica
hay muchos reactivos que pueden llevar a
cabo esas reacciones redox en el cuerpo
usualmente lo hace el sistema n además
nh acabamos de estudiar eso
si vemos esta molécula de aquí podemos
ver que es un aquí no la si podemos ver
la porción venzo quignón a de esta
molécula y ésta se llama uvic y no la
uvi se refiere a que ésta es ubicua este
compuesto se encuentra en todos lados se
encuentra en todas las células en la
naturaleza otro nombre para denominarla
es coenzima q esta es una parte muy
importante en la cadena de transporte de
electrones y si observamos la uvic y no
na pasando a esta molécula de la derecha
podemos ver que es un análogo de la
hidroquinona esta es uvi y nole
estos carbonos están siendo reducidos
debido a debido a esta reacción química
que dibujé aquí entonces la wiki nona
está siendo reducida a big in all y si
la uvi quiñones está siendo reducida
algo más debe de estar siendo oxidado
por lo que nh está siendo oxidado
además el nh es el que tiene este y duro
aquí que funciona como un agente
reductor entonces aquí nh está actuando
como un agente reductor
el agente para la reducción de winona a
la molécula de vic y no la del lado
derecho
es tan solo una simplificación de una
parte de la cadena de transporte de
electrones en la que se transportan
electrones que eventualmente conlleva a
la fosforilación oxidativa así como a
síntesis de atp que por supuesto nos da
energía esto no está destinado a ser un
detalle exhaustivo de esos procesos
bioquímicos sólo es para mostrarles cómo
se puede analizar a la bioquímica usando
conocimiento básico de química orgánica
así como la importancia a tn además y nh
en los sistemas biológicos